[Musique]
on est dans les starting bloc les
dernières animations qui nous arrivent
le matériel est distribué les affiches
tout le monde s'installe on est dans les
star team block pour cette
année on a énormément de nouvelles
communes qui nous ont rejoint pour
participer au Téléton cette année donc
on est très content des nouvelles
structures des entreprises des écoles
beaucoup de nouvelles écoles sur le
secteur donc ça c'est une super nouvelle
de toucher les plus jeunes et on a aussi
des résidences senior donc on on va
faire toutes les agges tous les
activités possibles de du sport bien sûr
parce que cette année le thème c'est
musclle ton Téléton et également bah des
repas comme d'habitude parce que pour le
Téléton on mange bien en général les
crêpes et les ballons c'est bien c'est
notre
tradition on a énormément de rel 24
heures on va avoir 24 heures de grimpe à
monini 24 heures de marche à bois d'Ary
24 heures de rameur à maison la fit 24
heur de badminton enfin voilà on a
vraiment des des sportifs hyper
mobilisés pour faire des fils rouges
pendant 24 he et puis plein d'activités
sportives un petit peu partout et puis
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure on muscle
les papilles aussi en mangeant on muscle
les zigomatiques avec des spectacles du
théâtre d'impro voilà plein de petit
petites choses super
sympa sur le territoire à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui on est à 328 animations
pour notre secteur Yveline est et puis
on a à peu près
120 120 associations qui sont mobilisées
un petit peu partout sur le territoire
on aimerait bien faire aussi bien que
l'année dernière on avait fait 331000 €
sur notre secteur l'année dernière donc
effectivement on aait bien dép ce
montant parce qu'on sait que on a des
programmes de recherche qui dépendent de
la collecte et puis de la mobilisation
des bénévoles et des participants sur le
terrain ce qui est important pour nous
c'est de pouvoir financer ces programmes
de recherche sur plusieurs
[Musique]
années